what is like advice you would give to
somebody who has all of the tools
necessary to make this [ __ ] work but
just really can't get over the hump
maybe
[ __ ] build a great team
because i mean it's not it's not just me
and blast like of course crazy to say
just me and blast like we still got
four employees on full payroll well
early on it was just youtube though well
early on it was just us two i mean we
had videographer you know i'm saying so
he was trailing us and then taking all
the pictures and all the bts right um
but i think
right after
probably like a little bit after that
first six tape that's when we actually
nah actually during the first six tape
that's when we started hiring people so
we made like our first hire her name is
allison so she's our general manager and
she's our she's a blast tour manager too
so but same time everybody is like super
qualified like alison went to school and
got a degree in music business and audio
engineering wow so she qualified to have
these idea conversations on stage as a
tour manager and then she's also
qualified to you know have those first
conversations run the email right be the
first responder we're just talking about
actual business logistics so you know
that's and that's really like a constant
theme throughout the whole company like
everybody is highly qualified for the
job they do but i would say the same
thing for artists that's in that
position like
i mean obviously i don't i'm really a
proponent of like you know reading the
manager to you got some [ __ ] to manage
you know what i'm saying like if you're
not overwhelmed with [ __ ]
you really don't need a manager at that
point you know what i mean you just
really need somebody to actually help
you probably funnel your ideas and
actually like get to the point because
you can only be one place at one time so
if you want to be in the studio you may
need somebody to help you make the merch
really creative on that
because blast is really an anomaly when
it comes to doing all that [ __ ] i really
just lied yeah it's really just him and
like i mean russ i guess was similar but
i mean i don't think russell's a creator
tyler
but yeah i mean just like in terms of
like engineering yourself
yeah but i don't even think they do
graphics though i was going to say the
one thing i'm not sure russ is making
his own
i don't think he's photoshopping bro
we went on tour for this uh this tour in
september
first city was seattle so you know they
got show graphics and [ __ ] on yeah so
blast is like i'm not happy with the
graphic that like the graphic designer
delivered me so i'm just about to chill
today literally spent 14 hours in the
hotel making this whole show graphic for
the concert wow so it was like an hour
and a half reel of a whole bunch of [ __ ]
going but he created that himself what's
going on behind him exactly while he's
performing he made that himself made all
that [ __ ] so it's just like for me you
know it's like a cheat code at the end
of the day it's like you don't really
got to outsource that much
can you save money facts is the
definition of vertical integration like
all money in for sure